adam let's talk uh look your league is
uh at 96 vaccination rate uh uh on your
among your players uh but there's so
much talk about one of the guys who
hasn't done it kyrie irving and so now
and you have said look this is not an
nba against kyrie or versus kai rethink
this is a
new york city law or regulation
and how it pertains to kyrie yet it is
an issue that impacts
the product that's put on the floor
if you could sit down with kyrie irving
what would you tell him
i'd tell him to get vaccinated first and
foremost for himself
and his family
next for his teammates
and his community and also for the
league that i know he cares so much
about
i understand you know that it's not just
kyrie there are people in this country
who disagree with the notion of getting
vaccinated but at least from everything
that i understand
science is firmly on the side of getting
vaccinated and this is in essence a
miracle vaccine think where we were
ernie
you know when we first stopped this
season and we all spoke and then when we
went into the bubble and we started last
season
and then this vaccine came along
and it's already saved tens of millions
of lives
and i think at some point you know for
kyrie to be an engaged member of society
putting aside this league
he needs to get vaccinated and that's
you said that's the law in new york and
the law in new york is if you want to
play an arena if you want to visit an
arena you want to participate in an
activity in arena you need to be
vaccinated and that's where he finds
himself and that's where we are as a
league and here i am in milwaukee where
after we give out the rings tonight the
bucks will be playing the nets and i
wish you were here